under the brightest of skies this is the
darkest of places in srebrenica the
graves go off into the distance
thousands of bosnian muslim men and boys
were murdered here in july 1995.
shahida's husband and brother were both
killed her teenage son escaped death by
fleeing into the woods
um
[Applause]
was the worst massacre in europe since
the holocaust
inspired by the bosnian serbs plan to
purify their territory through so-called
ethnic cleansing
was the bosnian serb general who ordered
the killings
he promised the crowds of frightened
people that they'd be safe
just as his soldiers were isolating
muslim men and boys executing them and
then hiding their bodies
after the war a new region was created
for bosnian serbs now they want more
control but what they need is support
from powerful friends and that might be
coming
we meet the nationalist politician
volume pavlovic he looks towards serbia
and russia for the future and sees the
west as an enemy
in his mind srebrenica was not a
genocide
and the man convicted of those war
crimes
is innocent
you know
and that's why what happens here is so
important if bosnia falls apart it could
spark war in the balkans
international peacekeepers are still
patrolling here maintaining whatever
peace looks like for now
the capital sarajevo was under siege for
nearly four years
bosnians did this to each other little
wonder reconciliation has proved elusive
whether it's physical or mentally you
can still see the scars of war
everywhere
in bosnia now peace has endured but at
the moment it looks fragile and
vulnerable this is a nation that is
weighed down by the violence of its own
past
looming over this is the threat of
russian intervention with moscow
exerting ever more influence over the
country we have a very very strong
historical relations with the russians
and we believe in russians
personally i love russians more than
americans
thirty years ago ethnic tensions ripped
this country apart yet now hints of the
same menacing rhetoric
the solution of bosnia herzegovina will
happen
if the situation in this state continues
like this if
bosniacs has the bigger name the biggest
nation in the whole whole state
in srebrenica the past still frames the
present the trauma never goes away
shahida hopes for a brighter future but
she's not optimistic
[Music]
a lack of progress that tells you
everything
bosnia faces the ghastly prospect that
the next war could start before they
finish burying the victims of the last
one
adam parsons sky news bosnia